Mark: Okay, let's kill Hitler!
Mark: I think that's a-
Bob: fuck.
Mark: Le-Let's go kill Hitler.
Mark: I think that's a-
Bob: Well I assume it will at least be as easy as this.
Mark: No, no. I think it'll be much better. If we go kill Hitler...
it'll be fine. I'm tellin' ya, man, Hitler is gonna go down. We're gonna each shoot him in his nut,
Mark: like each one, one nut-
Bob: You want left- You want left nut or right nut?
Mark: Uhh, I'm more partial tooooo... left nut,
like, to be honest, I don't know if that's what you want, ...
Bob: Oh my god, I didn't see this before...
Mark: What?
Bob: ... and I'm a little sad about that.
Bob: My character's name is Harry Hawker.
Mark: Fffuck, what a name!
Bob: That- That's fucking legendary.
Mark: What a man!
Mark: Geez!
Bob: I'm the- I'm the Hawkinest motherfucker you've ever had Hawked.
Mark: Fuck yeah, ya are!
Fuck!
Alright, um, I- I've started a Kill the- Kill the Hitler
thing, thingamaBOBer.
Bob: Yeah, I guess I'll join you or whatever.
Mark: Yeah, do that, that'd be nice.
Bob: Friennnnd.
Mark: Alright, cool, whatever.
Bob: Fffffriennnd.
Mark: Man, I don't even have any skills to unlock.
Mark: It sure would be great to have all these skills.
Bob: Nah.
Mark: Mnyeh.
Bob: Meh.
Mark: D'yea nah.
Mark: A'right, you ready?
Bob: Did ya almost barf there?
Mark: Little bit, yeah.
*various barfing sound effects*
Mark: Alright, let's change the course of the war, I guess.
Bob: Well, uh, killing the guy instigating the bad stuff in the war probably would change
the course of the war pretty dramatically, ...
Mark: It probably would.
Bob: ... maybe we should just kill him.
Mark: Yeah, okay.
Skoosh!
Bob: Man, what an undeserved position for us to suddenly be in.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: Alright, we've done all the hard work, let's go kill Hitler.   Mark: *laughing*
Mark: Yea, we failed like nineteen times, good thing we can respawn indefinitely.  Bob: *laughing*
Let's kill Hitler.
Bob: We killed like thirty guys trying several times to defeat that one convoy, whatever the hell that was.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: Let's just do this.
Mark: You know, actually, we don't know what we were doing there,
we were just kinda like... in the middle of nothin', but... let's kill Hitler.
Bob: We're soldiers, okay, we don't ask questions.
Mark: Riiiiiight...
Bob: We just... we just murder.
Mark: Aaah... okay, alright.
Oh, there's another sniper over there.
Is he looking at me?
Bob: Oh, yeah. Um, actually, we are red right now.
Mark: I- oh yeah, okay, alright then.
Bob: Oh, fun! Did you just die?
Mark: No, I got hit by the sniper; he's gonna get hit, though.
RIGHT IN HIS FACE!
~ahahaha~
Got him.
Bob: Oh! I shot at him too, I don't know which one of us did that.
Mark: Uh, I got the slow-mo, so I'm pretty sure it was mmm- prolly you.
Bob: Whatever.
Oh, shit. This is a sniper- no.
Mark: Hi!
Bob: Oh lord.
Mark: Yea? You okay?
Bob: Oh god, I'm bleeding out!
Mark: Lord can't save you now, but I can!
Don't shoot me, anybody!
Don't shoot me. Aw, someone shot me.
Bob: They're shootin' you, they're shootin' you!
They're shootin' you!
Mark: Oddly enough, they seem to be shooting me!
I don't know how this came to this... juncture!
I'm beginning to think that may be announcing our presence.
Bob: Wow!
Mark: Maybe standing atop this mountain, shouting "Let's kill Hitler,"...
Bob: *laughing* Let's- Let's kill Hitler, yeaaah!
Mark: Hitler's down there, Eva Braun's... I- she's not cool!
... Wot?
Bob: What in the-
Mark: What?
Bob: What did I just get hit by, thought I was safe!
Mark: By a sniper, I g- if I had to guess.
Bob: Oh no, there's a fucking guy right over there.
Mark: Alright, I'm gonna j- imma getcha.
Here we go! You're gettin' up!
Bob: I'm providing covering fire.
Mark: I see that! Very efficient.
Bob: Alright, I'm pushing.
Mark: Alright, cool.
Bob: Oh god!
Mark: Wait, you were pushing in a different direction than I was.
Did you try to jump across the chasm?
Bob: I didn't realize- I thought there was like a bridge,
I didn't realize we're not doing that.
Alright, let's go!
Mark: Alright. Well, artillery's gonna be down there in the water- Ow!
Who's behind us?
Who is over there? I don't see any-
Bob: That's a douchebag over there.
Mark: ... ohhhhh. Boink!
Oh no. That- that hurts a lot.
Well, I missed.
Bob: Oh no! Oh wow! Wow ow...
Mark: Ohhhh nooo!
Whuff.
Bob: Bada... bop!
Ah, good kill.
Mark: Thanks.
Bob: I wish there was a way to like spot people. Is that
a mechanic that we're just not taking advantage of?
Mark: Probably.
I mean, I hella imagine it is.
'Cause that seems like a thing that happens.
Bob: Where was that guy shooting from?
There were just bullets coming from a place,
and then I looked at that place
and then there was no guy there.
Mark: Huh. A mystery...
Bob: There's a guy over here!
WHAT'S UP, DOUCHEBAG?
What's up, bitch?
How do you like me NOW?
Mark: I like you a lot.
I consider you one of my closest friends.
Both: OOOOOOOH!
Mark: Through the power of love!
Wow, ricochet?
Bob: Please go in his nuts!
Mark: What?!
Bob: Oh, wow.
Mark: Oh my god.
Bob: That's not what I thought was gonna happen.
Mark: Fuck, dude!
Bob: I mean, I fucking wrecked that guy.
Mark: Yeah, you did! Oh my god!
Bob: Time to go, time to move, time to move!
Mark: Yeah, no joke.
I'm gonna heal real quick...
Bob: Jesus Christ.
Mark: Jesus.
Bob: I'll just hang out over here-
Wow! It hit me. Oh god.
Mark: Yeah. Anyway, I'm pretty sure it was my positive
reinforcement that really...
... really made that shot happen.
Bob: I believe you.
Mark: Alright.
Good stuff, guys. Oh! There.
Bob: Alright.
Mark: That is faaar away.
Bob: Yeah.
Mark: No, don't duck, come on.
Bob: You're, guys, waaay the fuck- I'm gonna push
up the bridge a little bit.
Mark: *Pfffffrt* Alright.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna flail, flail wildly...
You think Hitler knows we're coming for him?
You think he's aware of this situation?
Bob: He's just inside, like, having a snack like:
*weird accent* "Mmmm, I do lofe apples."
Mark: *same accent* "No-one trying to kill me, Hitler!"
Bob: "I haf been telling you, they haf the best apples."
Bob: "Why haf we not been having these all the time?"
Bob: That's definitely how he sounds.
Mark: That's- Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Bob: That impression is spot on, I know for a fact.
Mark: I mean, there's no physical evidence to what he
actually sounded like, so it's probably correct.
Bob: Yea. There are no recordings or anything, so...
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: ... 'cause that... the war...
the great war took place in the time before audio, so...
Mark: I am pretty sure it was medieval times.
I'm not- not a 100 % on that, but I'm pretty sure.
Bob: It actually started at a medieval times restaurant.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: Um, because people were fighting
over seats, because everyone wanted to be
in the Blue Knights' (?) corner,
um, 'cause that one is the best.
Mark: I can't disagree,
... shit, I'm...
Bob: I actually don't know that much about medieval times-
I'm just standing in the open.
I am yellow. Are you yellow?
I'm yellow.
Mark: I was yellow, I'm black, apparently.
Bob: Uhhh, okay, I don't know why ya
have to make it like that.
Mark: I'm just- Hey, you said it was yellow, man, so...
Bob: I don't know why you always have to make it about yourself.
Mark: Uh, pfft. I think you did that, so, whatever.
You know what? Fine. Just-
I'm yellow now. Is that better?
Bob: Actually, that does make me feel better.
Mark: Okay.
Bob: Ho-ho, that was a pretty long shot. Why was that not cool?
Mark: I dunno.
Bob: It's a cool shot.
Mark: You can get long shots, but they're
not always the best.
Or whatever, I don't know.
Did we kill everybody?
Bob: I was pretty proud- I mean,
seems like we kinda did, actually.
This "killing Hitler" is way easier
than blowing up that convoy or whatever the fuck we were doing before.
Mark: Yeah, whatever that was.
Bob: Why are we inside a question mark circle?
What are we supposed to do here?
Mark: Imma shoot this bird.
Mark: Death.
Bob: Jesus.
Bob: The birds just, like, disintegrate.
Mark: I just watched his corpse fall slowly into the sea.
It's actually quite sad, I don't know why I did that.
Hey look, a BWAM! ... Fuck.
Bob: I just watched his corpse
sink into the waves.
Mark: Fuck, bwam! There we go.
Was that a distraction?
Bob: Oh. Why is there a dead guy in the wall?
Is that an American? Holy fuck.
Mark: I don't know. American?
Bob: That is NOT good.
I'm going down; I don't know if this is the way we want to go,
but this is where I am.
Mark: I'll cover you from above!
... I don't know why I shouted that, but...
Bob: Are you shouting "Out of ammo! Reloading" right now?
Mark: I'm not, are you?
Hullulllll... Pffffrt.
Bob: Wow!
Mark: Right dead center in your gob.
Bob: I appreciate how surprised they all look.
Whenever it does the skeleton view,
it's always like, "Oh god!"
Mark: I think that's just how skeletons ARE! Ah, fuck.
Oh god, I'm about to be artillarooded!
Boom!
Okay, so where are you? Oh, you're down there. Okay.
Bob: I'm by the- OH, what the shit?!
Mark: I'M COMING!
I'm coming!
There's a sniper, by the way! Ow!
Shit!
I, yeah, I didn't make it.
Bob: What the fuck?
Mark: I don't know.
Bob: Okay.
It went from- we were fighting the idiots on
the outside part... to elite sniper force on the inside.
Mark: I think they call it the SS,
... the Super Snipers.
Bob: I don't think that was what that stood for.
Mark: No, no, I'm pretty sure.
That's what it is.
That's what I was taught.
Bob: Oh hey, so we're right here. Okay, so where the fuck was that sniper at?
Mark: Um, I couldn't tell, I never saw a glint.
I just saw "Ah! You're being shot at!", and then...
... darkness consumed me.
Bob: Ohhhh, I got him in the face!
Oh, good shot.
Mark: Thank you.
Bob: There's a guy over there in the distance, but I don't
know where he's at.
Mark: I'm not seeing aaanything.
Bob: Am I going the right way?
I feel like I'm going a different way, suddenly.
Mark: Yea, you're going a different way than you were,
but hey, you do you, man, so long as you sniff out Hitler.
I think that's all that matters.
Bob: Oh, I'm sniffin' him.
Mark: Mm, get that pungent Hitler smell.
Bob: *sniffing*
Wow, okay, that was...
Bob: Oh my god!
Mark: Was that from behind?
Bob: I don't know, man.
I'm sniffing Hitler.
Mark: Yea, you caught a whiff?
Bob: Oh yeah.
Mark: You got a scent?
Bob: Pretty much.
Mark: I have no idea where this is.
Oh! If you keep going the way you're going, you can go
up on that church tower, you'd have like the world's
best vantage point.
Bob: That is exactly what I meant to do from the beginning.
Mark: Dude, you're so smart!
Bob: Oh god, there's like a placed machine gun here!
Oh, fuck's sake!
Mark: Hang on, where- is there a guy in it? Can I help?
Bob: Yeah, can you snipe him out a little bit?
Mark: I don't... think I got a...
There's like big walls blocking me- I FELL IN A HOLE! God damnit.
Yeah, I've got- for some reason, this one's got
the vantage to where you are blocked.
Bob: AH! Ah-ah. Ah.
Mark: I see this guy. I'm gonna shoot the shit outta him.
He's climbin' stairs.
He has no idea.
The death... is about to be-
-FALL HIM!
Bob: Ah, can't go over here.
There's nothing I can do about that machine gun placement.
Mark: Yeah? Grenades?
Bob: Uh, I'm gonna- I tried it, I can't-
If I peek out even remotely to where i can like see to what I'm throwing grenade at, ...
Mark: Yeah?
Bob: I'm just done.
Mark: Okay, so was it by that big concrete thing? The machine gun or something?
Bob: Yes.
Gonna keep moving around this way.
Mark: Yea.
I'm gonna- I'm gonna leave my vantage point for a second.
Bob: I found the sniper!
Mark: Whoa, you did?
Bob: Found the sniper. He's glinting. He's looking at me.
Mark: *ominously* He's glinting!
Bob: Take your shot, motherfucker!
Mark: Oh. He's looking at me.
No, he's looking at me.
Bob: Oh, is he? Is he?
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: So I can peek out and get him?
NO! He fucking looked right at me!
Mark: Oh god, you're so far!
You're so far!
Ah! I'm coming, buddy!
Don't you worry!
I'm gonna make it!
Bob: I'm extremely far away from you.
Mark: Nonononono! Just believe!
Believe in the power of love!
Believe!
Bob: Actually, you're not that far, you'll probably get me.
Just watch out for that sniper bitch.
Mark: I killed him! It's okay!
Mark: I'm gonna make it!
Bob: Okay, good!
Mark: *sounds of effort* Believe!
Bob: Lots of time, lots of time.
Mark: Believe in the power of love!
I found you.
Bob: I believe, I believe, I believe.
Mark: I found you.
Bob: Hey, what's up? I knew you'd come for me.
Mark: Yeah.
'Cause of the love.
Bob: This cover is not really large enough for both of us. This is kind of a problem.
Mark: Oh shit. I ran out of breath.
That guy's tough.
Oh, nevermind.
Bob: Ohhh, eye shot.
Mark: Why do I have an option to hang here? Hey, I'm just gonna hang here.
Don't worry about me, man.
Bob: Careful, this is like Zelda, are you about to run out of stamina?
Mark: Uhhhhhhhhhhh...
Probably not, but I'm gonna climb back up.
Okay. Don't know why I did that.
Bob: That's cool.
Mark: Yea, thank, man.
Bob: Um, do you happen to have any extra health packs, per chance?
Mark: Nooo, I- Oh wait. Yes, I do. How do I use it on you, though?
Bob: I... don't know if that's possible.
This is where that thing- The red thing on the map is the machine gun.
Mark: Oh!
Bob: Oh hey!
We're- It's this big metal box here, that we're like...
Mark: Ohhh.
So, if we-
Bob: This is the fucking machine gun bitch.
Mark: It's a pillbox. Okay, so if I just-
Bob: Don't go in front of it, don't go in front of it!
Mark: But if I throw- nevermind, that bounced off that. Why?
Bob: Did that go inside, or no?
Mark: No, it did not.
Wait.
Hang on.
I got an idea.
*sounds of effort*
Missed me.
Douche.
Alright, so there was, like, something, "Place satchel charge."
Here we go!
Alright, did that!
Bob: Oh, nice!
Mark: 'Kay. Add timer-
Oh, nevermind, okay. Adding timer just meant lighting the fuse, apparently.
Bob: Add timer- Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Mark: Alright. Ah, there we go!
Bob: Somebody needs to know what "timer" means".
Mark: Pillbox destroyed.
Bob: Oh my god, I just got so much ammo.
Mark: Nice.
Bob: Is that an AK-47? I mean, an MKB-42?
Mark: Yeah. Okay, that-
Bob: I appear to have an AK-47 now.
Mark: Okay!
Bob: I mean, an MKB-42.
Mark: Okay. A'right. I believe both.
Bob: Is that yellow dot Hitler?
Are we getting close to Hit- Ohhh. No. I don't think we're close to Hitler.
Mark: Nah. I think Hitler's inside the...
Bob: Look at that big fucking circle.
Mark: Ooo, dude, here! Come over here. Yea, right here.
Bob: A'right.
Hang on- Let me do this.
Well.
That is not even remotely what I meant.
Mark: What, were you, uh- were you-
Bob: I just fucking threw a grenade into the distance.
Mark: I just, like, hang off the edge and I'm like, alright, okay.
Well, that was-
Bob: I just wanna fucking watch the world burn, man, just whatever.
Mark: Oh. This is like a machine gun sniper rifle.
If you want that, that exists.
Alright.
So, in here...
... supposedly.
Bob: Fuck yea.
Mark: O-Oh.
Oooh, we're above 'em.
Hell yeah. We can totally kill Hitler from up here.
Oh.
Ooooh.
I think this might be where Hitler is.
Bob: Oh, is this- Are we about to totally kill the shit out of Hitler?
Mark: Dude!
I think... maybe we might.
Is that Hitler?
Naaah, that's not- that's not Hitler.
Bob: Where's Hitler?
Mark: I- I don't know.
That's not Hitler.
Bob: Is this "sabotage failsafe" and (??) like places we're supposed to go?
Mark: What?
Bob: Should I just start spraying with my gun randomly, is that the strategy, or...
Mark: I think maybe, just for once...
Maybe...
Bob: Maybe don't do that?
Mark: Maybe not. I mean,
you do you. Hey, that guy's runnin'. Why is he runnin'?
What're you in a hurry for, buddy?
Oh, is that a sniper? Oh, that's a sniper.
You spyin' the sniper that I'm spyin'?
Bob: I'm gonna spread out a little bit.
Mark: Alright, cool.
Bob: See what- See where I'm in it?
See what I is doin'?
Mark: Wow!
Dude!
Bob: It's a- It's Assassin's Creed over here.
Mark: How'd you learn to do that?
Bob: It's just, whatever, just pushed the button.
Mark: Dude, that's so cool!
Okay. So I'm just gonna stay up here and cover you from up here. You-
Bob: Okay, I'm kinda stuck now, sooooo...
Mark: Go down. Drop down a bit.
Y-You've got more yellow below you- There you go.
Bob: AH! Okay.
Mark: See?
Bob: Oh jeez. Okay.
Oh, there's fucking guys here.
Mark: So the danger is - don't get dropped.
I think you have a silenced pistol; use that.
Oh! The Führer is on the move!
Bob: Oh, okay. I thought it was like "Attention! Kill those fucking guys!"
Mark: Wait, wait, wait!
Wait a minute!
Wait! Wait!
Bob: Can you see him from where you are?
Wait!
Oh, fucking- it was a right on-
OHHH MY GOD, is this Hitler?
Ths better be Hitler!
OHHHH!
Bob: Did you just do that?
Mark: I FUCKING KILLED HITLER!
Bob: Did you just straight kill Hitler?
Mark: Y-Yeah!
Oh god, they're mad!
Bob: Wow.
Mark: What- Oh fuck.
Bob: Oh, they're mad. Oh, really. Are they?
Mark: They're real mad.
Bob: Are they angry at us about this?
Mark: Oh, aish. I did a goof.
Sorry! Shouldn't have taken that shot!
Bob: Eh, we're fine.
Mark: Are we?
Bob: Let's kill all these fucking guys.
God dangit.
Oh god, I'm bleeding out! I think I got hit by a sniper.
Mark: Oh no!
I'll try to come to you!
Bob: Ah, shit.
Mark: Hang on.
Bob: I should've repositioned to cover, I was just like, shooting.
Mark: Fuck! Nop, nope.
Climb on that, okay. I might be a sitting target,
climbing this pipe.
Bob: This is gonna take forever for you to climb over all the way!
Mark: Oh gawd no!
Bob: You're so fucked!
Mark: Hang on!
Bob: Oh no, I should've come back.
Mark: Nononono, you're good. You're good, man.
I'm almost there.
Bob: But we killed Hitler!
Mark: I thought that's the end of the mission.
Ow! Oh god.
Bob: Oh, hey!
Hey, buddy!
Mark: *sounds of maximum effort*
Bob: We should probably...
We should probably find some cover.
Mark: What?
Bob: Well, I'm over here in cover.
Mark: What? Oh. Cover? That's what you said?
I didn't hear that...
Alright, where are they at...
Bob: There are a selection of them to the right.
Pew!
Boom! Headshot, baby!
Mark: M-hm, hell yeah.
Bob: Boom. Boom, headshot, baby.
Mark: You headshot-ed a baby?
Bob: Man, I'm all out sniper ammo.
Mark: Dude.
Bob: Yeah.
Fucking savage, man. You have no idea.
Mark: Dude.
I just- I killed Hitler.
I would-
That's a- That's a debate. Would you kill baby Hitler?
Bob: Do I have to, like, look him in the eye while I'm killing the baby?
Mark: Whoa!!
Did you see that?
I dropped the boat on 'em.
Bob: *laughs*
Bob: Sick.
Mark: I don't know why it did that.
It was cool.
Bob: Hey, you know what, motherfucker?
I got nothing for you, how about that?
You know what?
You just keep doin' what you're doin'.
You seem to be doin' a good job of it.
Mark: Me?
Bob: Yeah.
Mark: Thanks, man.
Bob: You're pretty much holding up to- OOoh!
I thought I died!
But you- you're doing the killing.
Mak: Buhbubuhubububuh!
Pffffffrt!
Bob: What?
Mark: I don't know.
Mark: I dont know.
Bob: You see what the bullet was doing?
Mark: No, what did it do?
Bob: It was spinning around on the surface of his helmet for me.
Mark: What? I didn't see that!
Bob: It was all - WOOOOOwo!
Mark: Shit, dude.
Bob: Woo. Hey, dumbass.
I'm fucking directly above you.
Also, I'm above you.
Not fucking.
I'm just regular.
So where are we supposed to go, exactly?
Mark: I don't know.
Bob: Oh. We- We have to sabotage- No, we just have to escape?
Fuck, bro, let's get the fuck outta here.
Mark: Oh, yeah. What were we doing, murdering people?
Do we enjoy it?
Bob: The fuck's the point of that shit? That's pointless.
Mark: That's not- that's not the pipe.
I'm going down this pipe here.
Bob: We wanna go this way, don't we?
Mark: Nononono, there's a pipe here. See?
Weeeeee!
Bob: Oh.
Mark: Pipe, dude.
Bob: But that's not the way out, is it?
I was just gonna go back out the way we came.
Mark: "Escape Island" is over here.
We're going off to Escape Island, dude!
Bob: Oh, fuck. Well, geez! I didn't know that.
I'm gonna go escape the island with you!
Mark: Fuck yeah, man. Alright. Imma...
Imma just...
Bob: Wee, wow, that's a fun ride!
Mark: I know, right?
Kill Hitler, slide a pipe, it's a good way to live life!
Bob: It's fucking best day over here!
Mark: Fuck yea, not bad. Not for Hitler, though, ha!
Hey, you know what I mean?
Bob: Yeah.
On account he can't eat food anymore, 'cause you shot him in the face?
Mark: YEAAAH! Yeah, yea.
Bob: Eh, we'd miss food, too.
Do we just jump into the ocean, swimmin' away?
Mark: Oh, wait, it's the OTHER platform. Oops.
Sorry.
Bob: Oh, for fuck's sake.
Mark: How do we get over there?
Bob: That's what I get for fucking trusting you!
Mark: I'm sorry, man.
How the fuck do we get over there?
Bob: Do we have to fight through the main fore of this thing, and just go, "Ah!"
I leaped off, like an idiot.
What are those yellow things, by the way?
Mark: Yellow things?
Bob: Are those just guys that don't know where we're at?
Oh, those are totally dudes!
Mark: Yea, those are dudes.
Bob: Those are totally dudes!
Mark: Alright, I'm coming for ya!
Yyyyyiih, don't spot me.
Bob: Oh fuck. Oh geez. Hang on!
Hang on!
I'm gonna try and make it across to these boxes over here.
Mark: I see. That guy's got a-
Bob: *sounds of effort* ...That's not a hiding place!
That's not a hiding place! Okay.
This is a hiding place.
Mark: We're good, man, we're good.
Alright, I'm goin' for it.
Bob: There's a guy...
Yeah. Dude, I just wanna try and get the fuck outta here.
Mark: Yeah. I think, over here maybe, there's like...
Oh yeah, this leads up.
Bob: Ohhh?
So sneaky-peeky!
Mark: Wait.
This don't seem right.
Bob: What? Someone just yelled "Murder."
Mark: Murder?
"They murdered Hitler!" "Whaaaat? I can't believe it!"
Oooh, oops.
Bob: Oh, someone's going up here. Someone's going up here! Hide, hide, hide, hide!
Mark: No, get out the window! This is the escape!
Bob: Oh, okay. Right here, dear?
Mark: N- I well mean, a little farther away from the escape, but yeah, I guess so.
Bob: Whatever.
Mark: Oh! Nevermind.
Bob: Oh wait, whatever. We're both there.
We're the same guy again now.
Mark: Apparently- Ah, maybe I'm leaving you behind.
Okay, well, we killed Hhhhuh- there we go, then, I guess!
Bob: Fuckin' easy-peasy!
Mark: Yea, Hitler wa-
Bob: Killing Hitler was so much easier than the rest of this bullshit!
Mark: Yea! I don't know why that was such a big deal!
Bob: Well, we didn't locate the supplies or sabotaged any failsafes, but...
Mark: Eh, it's okay!
Bob: Guys, can you give us some credit?
Fucking... Killed the... leader of the... Axis-
Mark: Well I mean- I think I killed hitler.
Bob: Ah, I'm pretty sure you wouldn't have gotten there without me.
Mark: Ah-
Bob: Remember how you had to keep saving my life?
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: Remember that?
Mark: Ah, maybe.
Bob:  Remember how you're level 6 and I'm level 3? How did that happen?
Mark: So... you taught me about death...
... and that's what allowed me to have the will to kill Hitler.
Bob: *sniffing*
Bob: *laughs*
*outro plays*
(pandas)